Unknown: We're live right now. We're live. It just Yeah. Great. Go. Awesome. Welcome, pod two fifty six,
episode one zero four.
Today is 02/11/2026,
the year of our lord.
Joining me today are Scott and Tyler. What's up? The
recent board members of the two fifty six Foundation
Yo. Here to dismantle the proprietary mining empire.
Welcome.
Unknown: So what's new with this livestream?
Unknown: Okay.
D plus plus who
built an amazing
dashboard for HydraPool for the Telehash,
then an amazing overlay for the livestream for the telehash,
wanted to take it even a step further, and she put together this incredible
overlay that you're seeing on the Twitter
livestream right now,
which allows
several different
parameters to be monitored simultaneously,
including
this neat feature where you can chat with us
and your
message shows up on the livestream
when you send some sats to the two fifty six Foundation
to get your message on the board.
Unknown: Isn't that neat? I'm doing it. I'm doing it. Let's see.
Unknown: There's some QR codes. Scott's trying it out right now. You're sending some sats?
Unknown: I sent the sats.
Unknown: Okay. Oop.
We're live.
21 sats.
Thanks for the zap, Scott. Apostrophes don't show up.
Unknown: Did actually use punctuation on that.
Unknown: Yeah. So this monitoring dashboard, if you're if you're tuning in elsewhere or after the fact, and you're just curious to see this monitoring, you can go to
-.256f.org/monitor.html.
And
what do we got here? The total hash rate, the workers,
blocks found,
on chain and lightning donation QRs,
instructions to point hash rate to the two fifty six Foundation,
a Zap based live chat,
Bitcoin price, block height, total raised, and top miners and top workers.
Unknown: Oh, it looks like I've got
the highest difficulty.
Look at that. Twenty eight twenty eight point four six
billion.
Unknown: No way. Yeah.
Nice one. Almost there.
Unknown: With the Almost there. Trusty Apollo? Yeah. That's the Apollo.
Unknown: The So close. Difficulty
got a bit lower recently,
so you're even closer.
Yeah. What we what'd it do? Like, 15% downward or something? Yeah. Apparently, it's the biggest downward adjustment since the China mining ban.
Unknown: Oh, man. The Chinese mining ban was so much fun.
To
be mining back then, it was just
because it
just really validated
all the efforts home miners were putting into it because
Unknown: suddenly the hash rate went down, it got easier, you started getting more mining rewards. It was just a glorious time. What was home mining like back then? I was very new. I missed the boat. You were doing some writing at the time, right, Iko? About how to do it, some instructions, some things for Bitcoin Magazine. Tell me about it.
Unknown: Yeah. I published
my guide on how to mine Bitcoin at home in January
2021,
and that was after reading Diverters'
guide called Mining for the Streets.
Up until that point,
the narrative in the space was that
you shouldn't mine Bitcoin at home because it's
a waste of electricity,
you can't compete with the large miners, you're better off spending your money at an exchange,
it's too complicated,
like every excuse in the book.
And so it was very difficult to find anyone who would encourage you to mine Bitcoin at home, but
DiVerter had put out this guide explaining exactly how to do it and why it was a good idea,
and I just fell
into the rabbit hole head over heels at that point.
I took all of his advice
and started mining Bitcoin at home myself,
and I just documented my whole process and wrote my own guide,
and
that
became kind of popular
in the Bitcoin Twitter sphere,
and
I think it helps encourage a lot of people to try mining at home.
Think at the very least,
it really woke people up to understand that
maybe there was more to these
naysayers
and the narratives that they were spreading than
was on the surface.
But at that time, wasn't a bid axe,
so
mining meant
taking an industrial machine, a machine that's made
for sitting on a rack in a warehouse
and installing it in your home. So suddenly, you've got, like, 90 decibels of noise to deal with.
You've got a 130
degrees of hot air to deal with.
So and you need to plug it into 240 volt electricity sources. So,
you know, suddenly you're, like, modifying your home's electrical infrastructure,
the ventilation
system in your home,
trying to do clever tricks to dampen the sound while still allowing adequate airflow.
There was just a lot of really interesting problems,
and I think a lot of people really liked that hands on,
tangible
interaction
with Bitcoin,
because unless you were mining, was really just like
maybe the most tangible thing you had done up until that point was set up a Raspberry Pi as a Bitcoin node or something, which is cool, don't get me wrong,
but mining just kind of took things to a new level for a lot of us that were there, I think.
Unknown: I was huge into it. That was right around the time I moved into my office with free electricity. I was like, this is
Unknown: Dude, did you have two forty in there? I did. Well Hell yeah. So there was a
Unknown: I discovered
there was, like, this weird outlet on the wall in what room I think was the, like, copy machine room in the office before. Okay. And I opened up I switched off the breaker and opened up the outlet, because it was just one ten. But I opened it up and there was a red wire in there. I was like, Alright.
So traced it back and it was indeed wired for $2.20. It's just it wasn't connected. So I changed the outlet
over to, a two twenty one. I'd got the, like, proper, you know, 20 amp,
you know, the plug that looks like this.
Unknown: Yeah. I believe it's the NEMA six twenty p. Okay. Yes.
Unknown: Switched it over to that.
Plugged in my s nines.
It's like, this is gonna be amazing.
Unknown: S nines, you needed two twenty for? What what what was the minor during this, you know So the craziness? S17, s 19, M30? What was it? I think the S nineteens were out. Okay. Yeah. I think well, a lot of people had s nines, and that was the the neat part about the Chinese mining ban, suddenly S9s are profitable again.
Dude,
they started selling for a lot of money. I can't recall exactly what they were selling for, but I want to say at one point
during the 2021,
s nines were selling for more than a thousand dollars.
Unknown: Wow.
Unknown: Does anyone wanna fact check me on that? I can't recall exactly what they're selling for. I kinda remember getting a five pack of them on eBay
Unknown: of s nines.
And I wanna say they were just over, like,
$200
each.
Okay. Something
like that. But I remember being pretty stoked that I got a good deal. But, of course, they only came all of them came with the two twenty only power supplies, so that's why I was in that boat.
Oh, okay. Because that Yeah. Because There was, like, they made very similar APW three power supplies.
Unknown: If you weren't, like, looking closely, you couldn't tell. It was just, like, written on the side whether it was Oh, that's right. Because when Brad Cuddy showed up with a pallet of them at temps, like, half of them were one twenty and half of them weren't.
Because now they're getting handed out for free on pallets.
Unknown: Yeah. Yeah. It's crazy.
I was running the miner I bought when I wrote my guide was a What's Miner M30S
plus
82 terahash model.
And during the Chinese mining ban, dude, I was like
at my power rate, which I think was like 13¢,
maybe 11¢ a kilowatt hour. I can't remember.
At my electricity rate, I was mining
I was basically purchasing
non KYC Bitcoin
via my electric bill for, like,
60 to 70%
below spot trading price Yeah. At some points.
Unknown: And how how long did that glory last?
Unknown: It wasn't very long. It was pretty short lived, but it was so awesome
when it was happening.
Unknown: You remember the
coal mine incident, the Chinese coal mine incident?
Was just reading about that the other day.
Unknown: Refresh my memory. I'm, like, vaguely recalling
something about a coal mine. It was the
Unknown: Xianjiang,
x I n j I a n g. Xinjiang
coal mine disaster,
in April 2021.
And it was like
this pretty, like, devastating coal mine collapsed in China.
But I guess that triggered
a big safety review of all the coal mines in that area, which is big coal mining part of China, I guess.
And as a result of that, a massive number of miners shut off because
they were like in addition to coal mining, I guess they were also Bitcoin mining because electricity was very, very cheap there due to the, like, number of coal fired power plants, I guess.
So a huge I I I guess a lot of the hash rate also shut off because of that.
Maybe because it also been just recently banned in China.
Unknown: Right.
Unknown: How do they enforce banning it? Like, I I don't know. You just can see that they were mining at such a large scale, you could see the electrical profile because it still seems like you could mine in your house and get away with that. Dude, I have I have to think a lot of the enforcement
Unknown: was, like, just self enforced. Yeah.
You
you've got to think, at a certain level,
when a government starts ratcheting up the threat of violence against you and
telling you they're going to
confiscate your property, they're gonna lock you in a cage, they're gonna charge you hundreds of thousands of dollars in fines,
and that's coming from a United States perspective. God only knows what the kinds of threats a communist government, like
the Communist Party of China,
is threatening their citizens with to stay
within the bounds of the law.
But
all that is to say, you gotta think at a certain point when the government is making these threats of violence toward individuals,
individuals are going to assess the risk and the reward.
When it's really looking like that risk heavily outweighs
the reward they're getting,
I think they they're gonna be incentivized to stop
Unknown: doing the risky activity. Right? And they'll do massive surveillance. Right? So your your chances of getting caught are, are pretty high, I'd imagine. I think any you know, doing any sort of business at all in China requires quite a bit of approval from the government, the whether it's local government or or whatever. So
Yeah. I gotta imagine if
whatever you're doing falls out of favor,
you don't wanna
mess around and do it anyways.
Unknown: Right.
Yeah. And who knows? Like,
they'd probably make your whole family disappear
if you got caught doing something they don't like.
Unknown: It's interesting too because Bitmain and MicroBT, I mean, they're so big. Like, there's definitely government officials a part of those companies.
Unknown: Just interesting to think about. What was the the MicroBT guy went to jail, like
Unknown: Oh, really? I didn't know that. Yeah.
Unknown: Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. What? For what? For mining Bitcoin?
Unknown: Oh, gosh. Oh, gosh. I think I have it in my search history here. Was looking at For a closed source mining firmware?
Yeah. They were just so pissed off that he was doing closed source. He just, like, threw that guy in jail.
No. There so there's some drama. So the the guy who started the What's Minor Project at MicroBT came from Bitmain,
and there was some accusation of stealing trade secrets
and
back and forth. And I believe he
went to jail briefly.
Crazy. There isn't a ton of details on it, but,
yeah. I think I think it was
I mean, it may very well have been some retribution from Bitmain.
Unknown: Yeah. It's gotta be pretty small select group of people out there that have this
knowledge of designing these high performance
ASIC chips.
Unknown: Not many people out there doing it. Yeah, it doesn't help that they don't share the documentation
either.
Unknown: Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I feel like
talking with some of these other ASIC manufacturers,
they all have
previous TSMC employees
either on their board or as founding members of the company.
To get an allocation, have to do that, basically? I think it's just to navigate that whole system because it's so crazy. They
don't have TSMC is
doesn't have that many customers, and the ones they do have are so big. To get anything out of there has gotta be crazy and, like,
both just politically and,
technically. Right? It's
crazy expensive, crazy complicated.
Yeah. It's gotta be wild. I guess, you know, MicroBT is famously at Samsung, but it's gotta be a similar deal.
Yeah. I imagine. I mean, even that whole industry, right, it's so there's so few people in the semiconductor industry.
It's it's wild. Like, if you look at the history of these companies, they're all, like,
just came from one other company. Like, the founder of TSMC,
Morris Chang, is was, like, a VP at Texas Instruments for a long time. I mean, they
they
yeah. It's just a very small group, and,
you know, Apple started their semiconductor program by acquiring
PA Semi,
which was founded by some people from TI, I wanna say. Like, you know, the ex Motorola people, like, they all
all the executives in these things are just
Unknown: kinda shuffling around. It's really So Texas Instruments was, like, fabbing their own chips at one point?
Unknown: Yes. Yeah. They have been for a long time. They're, like, an early pioneer in the space, like Silicon Valley and, Texas, obviously.
They
they invented a lot of this stuff.
I think it was like Texas Instruments, Motorola
were like the original,
like, big players
in the, like, integrated circuit semiconductor industry.
And all the people that, like, started that, you know, left to found their own companies, and then it got all acquired and moved around.
Unknown: Does Texas Instruments still
produce like, are they still running a fab Yeah. Today? Yeah. I believe they have one in Texas.
Unknown: That's cool. You know, they're not making, like, three nanometer ASICs,
but there's a lot of semiconductors in the world that
are nowhere near 300 nanometers.
That's just for, like, high performance computing type stuff.
Unknown: Interesting.
Unknown: We're getting some zaps coming through.
Unknown: Any good comments?
Unknown: Dylan only sent us one SAT, so I shamed him for a message. One SAT? Come on. Can't believe I bought an S9 for $100 But he felt bad, so there were another nine ninety nine SATs that came through. Oh, nice. There we go, Dylan.
And Ryan, two fifty six SATs. It's about sending a message. I didn't know that GIFs work. We got a GIF here of the Joker.
Alright.
Burning all the the money from the Dark Knight. I like that.
We are monetizing them.
Yeah.
So what's been going on this week?
Unknown: Well,
that's a great question.
I know I've kinda had my head down in, like, 256
Land,
trying to get some
proposals together with the developers to submit to the board,
which is you guys.
And
Unknown: Deny it. No. Deny it.
Unknown: Yeah. I'm not I'm not really selling it here. Look.
These proposals are gonna be great.
We're
definitely gonna dismantle the proprietary mining empire.
Your money is safe with us.
So Alright. Fine. Approved. Okay. Great. Thank you.
But, yeah, I'm hoping to get those
you know, we wanna renew the cycle for
Mugena Mining firmware. We wanna renew the cycle for LeverBoard.
We wanna renew the cycle for HydroPool.
Just
getting those projects from zero to one has
really given us a glimpse
into
what is possible,
having a completely open source mining stack, and it's
really motivated us to
continue improving on all of these projects
so that other people can
use these as tools for their own development and
hopefully make the Bitcoin ecosystem a more
censorship resistant,
open and decentralized
bed of innovation
like it should be.
Unknown: I think it's working.
Unknown: Yeah, I think so too. I think we're gaining some traction. I think it's working. The excitement is really high. I mean,
Unknown: there's still a long way to go. Don't get me wrong. But Yeah. People are getting really fired up about this.
Unknown: I I think just, like like, getting the tools out there in the open and,
maybe
even putting
some guides together and just showing people
how they can use this stuff. For example,
Ryan built that sous vide
sous vide?
Sorry.
Built that system that he showed off at the telehouse where
he could, like, cook steak
by using the heat from the miners to warm up a bath of water. And
even though that's
not the
end goal of the open source mining stack that we're building, that's just one neat implementation
and a reference
for other people to look at and help them generate some ideas about what's possible with this stuff
and, you know, get their hands on it and see how it's working. So I just I think the more we can
make projects like that and guides like that and show people
some neat ideas, I think the more wheels are going to start turning
and
I hope to see
people actually building
successful
businesses on a foundation of open source tech. And I think
we're there. I think that's very close.
Unknown: Businesses that we haven't even thought of yet. Yeah, I've been thinking about that a lot this week.
Dream bigger. Exactly.
Well, especially after you see a lot of cool new products coming out, like just what comes to mind is this super heat water heater that came out a couple months ago.
One of their guys should be at the heat pump some, which is cool because we can chat with them.
I mean, it looks awesome. It's a it's it's an awesome product. It's a huge market. I think like American water heaters is something like five set of hash if they were all mining.
But
what I keep
finding yeah. It's crazy.
Dude. What I keep finding though is like everybody seems to be trying to tackle these
base layer problems with the mining stack control from the firmware perspective,
custom size hash boards,
etcetera. And
It'd just be so much easier if every new company idea, every new product idea didn't have to go redo that step. Yeah, totally.
Unknown: I'm
excited to see
Block release
ASICs,
you know, via Proto
and sell them a la carte
with supporting documentation.
I'm I'm excited for anybody to do that, but, you know, especially Block because they've
Proto because they've
been supportive of the two fifty six Foundation,
they've been supportive of open source in general,
and
I see a lot of potential there for you know, chips
being sold individually with supporting documentation.
And then you couple that with
having designs
where
you can just download the key CAD files and change the form factor to fit your neat application.
And, yeah, like you said, you don't have to reinvent the wheel.
Mhmm.
Unknown: For the
to play as devil's advocate, for the purists out there, right, we're
we're committed to open source software and hardware.
What is the
the explanation for why an open source ASIC chip this is for Scott. I think he could answer this best.
Is it just not feasible?
Is it just not
economical?
Is it not necessary so long as these companies there's always bottlenecks. Right? I mean, you get to the bottom of any industry and it's like, okay. Shoot. TSMC and Samsung are the bottleneck of literally everything on earth, or you can do these thought experiments. But I'm just curious if you've given that any thought, if you've had that question brought up to you before.
Unknown: Yeah. Yeah. It comes up a lot. I think it would be fantastic.
I think we could definitely make an open source mining ASIC chip,
but the caveat
is that
we cannot make
a competitive one.
You know, like we were talking about earlier, getting into TSMC is insane. Right? Like,
big companies with tens of millions of dollars, well capitalized, still have trouble doing it. So
it's not exactly
accessible
to,
well, anyone. It's not accessible to anyone. It's it's incredibly expensive.
That said, we could and some people have talked about it. We had a cool conversation
about this,
last weekend on the OSMU town hall.
But,
you know, we could make a,
an ASIC that, you know, would have been nice ten years ago.
That that actually is accessible. It's still pretty expensive. Think, like, thousands of dollars, but it could be done.
It just
is a lot of work and it you know, people would see it and be like, what is what is this garbage? Right? We're talking about, like, I don't know,
100 megahash kind of thing. Right? Like, you know,
it's not gonna be very efficient. It'd still be really cool. It'd be a really cool project,
especially for someone who wants to, you know, get more into that field. Like, it's a different tool set for designing an ASIC. It's kind of a a different way of thinking.
We actually talked about it'd be really neat to make a sort of a FPGA bit axe.
FPGAs
are chips,
and they're sort of like
software reconfigurable
ASICs.
You you write
a code in a hardware description language. So it's code that describes how the hardware should be connected,
and then you kind of flash it to the FPGA,
and it's not a CPU. It's, like, actually running your logic.
I think that'd a pretty a pretty cool project. I saw a neat post today about writing that HDL, the hardware description language with AI. Apparently, it's quite good at it. Surprise. Surprise.
That'd be pretty neat. That'd be a cool way to,
experiment with sort of optimizing
how an ASIC is built.
Again, you're gonna have a very nonperformant,
minor at the end of the day, but still a fantastic
educational tool. I think that'd be really neat.
But then the so the other issue with making a a modern Bitcoin mining ASIC is that
it's not like PCBs where you just design it and you send it to the fab and they send you back
your boards. It's not like that with a chip foundry.
Right? It's
it's a much more collaborative process with the foundry.
You have to be like, well, here's what I wanna do. And they're like, well, here's what we can do. And you sort of make it work using
their tools,
and they have a,
like, a SDK
essentially for making chips. So they're like, okay. You make your chip using these components that we can do, that kind of thing.
And so
TSMC is not gonna let you open source their,
their design components.
No modern fab is.
So then there's that issue. So you can't really, like,
publish
a design for a mask set, which is the sort of the
stencils, if you will, for an ASIC,
because it contains a lot of proprietary information from other companies.
So that's that's a roadblock.
Unknown: Yeah. It's a good answer, though. Makes sense.
Unknown: In the future, maybe
if we start doing it, make some of the older ASICs now, and who knows where this can go, right? This field is Especially with AI.
Especially with AI. Yeah. It's just like one shot. It will be like,
yo,
Codex 5.3.
I wanna make a
two nanometer ASIC.
Make no mistakes.
Unknown: It's getting so good.
Like, I I just tangent on that. I'll play Rod. Tangent.
I have a skill file with Claude where I I defined a spec interview.
So you give it an idea. I wanna do this.
And it literally interviews you with multiple choice questions
until it has a comprehensive spec. I mean, the interview can last two hours.
Wow. And then it creates a markdown file with a spec, and then it, like, one shots it because it has the whole architecture, everything. And it's stuff I wouldn't think of. I'm not a dev, you know? Use this database, use this communication. I don't know this stuff. You know? You just say, I want x as the output,
and it interviews you. And if you can say like, I don't know the answer to this question. Just do what's recommended.
That's most of my answers. That's so neat.
Unknown: Man, this stuff is really exciting.
I feel like it's lacking in the hardware,
the EE side of things.
It certainly understands
electrical engineering and electronics. But as far as laying out a board, I don't know. I've spent all week so far just, like, manually clicking. I'm like,
sure. I could do this.
Unknown: Yeah. If it could see your KiCad and
Unknown: help you walk through that, that would be cool. Yeah. Yeah. It's ripe. I mean, it's gonna happen. I feel like there was a really neat article
that a bunch of people were retweeting from Matt Schumer called Something Big is Happening.
Unknown: I I had I did the classic bookmark, come back to it later. Yeah. It's really long.
Unknown: But
it's it's really neat. And one of the things that was in there he's talking about is
that the AI companies now are using AI to
improve on the AI models.
Right? It's like they're kinda building the tools, and that was one of the reasons why,
I guess, initial AI stuff development was focused on writing code.
And so then it could write code to improve itself.
And it's it's got that exponential,
development
now that comes from that.
So my hope is that now that we have these really good tools, right, it can it can branch out.
Unknown: I got one of those ClotBots running on a Raspberry Pi. Yeah.
And I
gave it access to
the API for our home assistant, which is monitoring all of our miners as heaters.
And I literally just said, build a monitoring dashboard.
It installed Docker. It installed Grafana.
It got a database.
It built out the whole Grafana dashboard,
different dashboards for, like, monitoring chip temps, and it would notify me if chips exceeded x degrees Celsius.
Things like, hey. Your thermostat's calling for heat. It's been ten minutes. There's no hash rate. The miner didn't turn on. It would monitor that and send me it's crazy.
Unknown: It did that all on its own? Yes.
Unknown: And it ripped through all my tokens, and then I got rate limited.
Unknown: So how does that part where are you buying the tokens from?
Unknown: So I have a a Claude, like, from the company Anthropic, a Claude subscription. They're one of the few that I like where it just uses your your monthly
subscription model token amount instead of, like, charging you per consumption because I don't wanna
burn through a credit card or something. Right. Yeah. Crazy.
It's getting very But
Unknown: like,
is there
can't you like host your own?
You could. Why do you have to give them money?
Unknown: Like, isn't this stuff all open source? Their models are not as far as I understand. Their models cannot be. You can't pull like Opus four point six as their newest model and run it locally on your GPU hardware.
There are open source models,
Olama, things like that.
Got it. Okay. But
it seems to be the sentiment is that Anthropix is the best at coding
and everyone's just throwing money at them.
Unknown: That part of it is closed source. Correct.
Unknown: Okay. Yeah. But we're tinkering with some GPUs in the basement that are you guys will see in a couple weeks. The loud things in this building are not miners. They're GPUs
running some local LLM
for that exact reason. So you don't have to pay money and your data's private. Are you gonna water cool those too?
We should. They're so freaking loud. It's those tiny little 2U server blade fans, you know? Yeah.
Unknown: So
people are buying all these Mac minis, right? Yeah. What are they doing with those?
Unknown: Basically, I did on a Raspberry Pi, I think the
simplicity value is because it's macOS,
you want to connect your agent, there you go. If you want to connect your agent to your iMessages
Unknown: or your Wait. Hold your Apple Notes. Eco, for those who aren't watching, Eco just rolled in a pallet of Mac minis. What are you doing, man? I know you did not buy those, Eco. Yeah. These are mine now. I'm spinning up some Cloudbots,
Unknown: bud. Really?
Unknown: No. They're
they belong to Bitcoin Park.
Unknown: Yeah. I actually don't know why it's all Mac minis. I think it's because people just easily tap into the, like, the iCloud walled garden with it. Okay. I don't know what these guys are planning on doing with these things, but they're
Unknown: they're up to something here at Bitcoin Park. So the idea is that, like, you wanna run it on a separate computer because you don't trust to run it on your, like, desktop.
Unknown: And it's running twenty four seven. I mean, I think Kali made a, like, a SaaS model of it where it just runs at some hosting service
and you get, you know, basically
a a VPS.
Unknown: So So you just need but it's still, like, communicating with, like, Anthropix
model hosted.
Unknown: Yes. You have to give it a brain
because the Mac minis, the Raspberry Pi, the VPSs, they're not the brain. You need to give it like a GPU brain.
If you wanted to do it for budget, I wanna get one of these Raspberry Pi AI hats. They make a hat that's like 40
tops, they call it, trillion operations per second. Oh, yeah. I've seen those. That looks neat. Yeah. I wonder how like, if I could just
control my miners from a Raspberry Pi,
Unknown: like, could you put this little AI hat on the Libre board? That'd be sick. But Yes. It doesn't sound like the Mac mini or the Raspberry Pi in this case is like doing
Unknown: AI computations. Right? It's like No. That's what that little AI hat though is. It's a dedicated AI
chip with eight gigs of VRAM on it.
Unknown: Okay. So then Yeah. Then you could run some of this stuff locally.
Unknown: Yes. Yeah.
Which would be cool. Be cool to have an AI chip on a mining control board.
Optimize hash rate. Make no mistakes.
Unknown: Mean, yeah. Auto tuning. Steak.
Right? Auto tuning, that's that's a big complicated task right now. You think you have, like, a 100 chips on the board. They all have, like, slightly different
characteristics.
Right? And so you got a prime combination of hash frequency and voltage that works best across
Unknown: all these chips. And they're all interconnected because they're connected. How does that work right now for us that are ignorant? You know, is it just a big feedback loop that's
stepping up in frequency slowly until a chip is happy? And then do you move on to the next, or do you have to do them all at once?
Unknown: So
it
at least with Bitmain a six, it's not really easy to well, you you can't really change the the voltage
to individual chips. You sort of change you can only change the voltage to all of them.
But then you can kinda tweak the voltage to each chip by changing the hash frequency of each one. So that'll, like, change how much voltage a particular chip drops and then, like, what all the ones,
connected in series to it get as a result.
I think as far as I understand it, the auto tuning algorithms are really just kinda guess and check. Like, you know, change a little bit, see how it does. Change a little bit, see how it does. That's why it can take a long time.
Right. And you sorta you need to, like, give it actual work to mine on, see how it does.
Unknown: And it must save its memory in some way, right? Because like on LuxOS for example, you can make these custom profiles, it will tune,
you know, for a little bit of time.
And then I think if you switch to a different profile and back, it's quicker, which to me indicates that it has some memory
Unknown: Well, I guess if you what it was happening. A profile that works for your hash board, you don't need to do as much guess and check anymore. Right? You can just go right to it. Okay.
You do need to you do need to kinda slowly adjust
things like the the hash frequency. You can't just or the voltage. You can't just, you know, go from
from, you know, two to three, and jump right up. You do need to do that slowly, but that's significantly faster than this, like, auto tuning process, which is finding the correct values.
So, yeah, I've seen the profile just kinda saves, like, alright. This is what worked for this dashboard.
Unknown: From a privacy perspective,
what information is Anthropic getting? Do they see everything that your agent sees?
When people do these brain
dumps and they're giving their agent access
to their signal messages and their credit cards and all of their personal preferences,
is that all going to Anthropic server or whatever
hosting provider server?
Unknown: Yeah. I I this is a good question. I I won't say I'm a 100% accurate, and I do wanna know the answer. My understanding is it knows the context, meaning,
like, if I have an environment variable with an API key on my Raspberry Pi so it can read my Gmail,
I think
Anthropix sees the context like, hey, he's pulling something from this Gmail account,
but I don't know if they can see my emails,
if that makes sense. Yeah.
So they they see pretty much all of what you're doing. I don't know if they see the details of what information is passing through that. Maybe
Unknown: an analogy is they see the metadata,
the what, where, when,
but not necessarily
the exact contents.
Unknown: Yeah, but a big risk with these Clawbots
is basically
all the knowledge lives in these skill files, they're markdown files.
And it's just a file that says, Hey, if you're working on Home Assistant stuff, like my prompt, if it had Home Assistant in the prompt, it would go read this skill that says when you're doing dealing with home assistant, here's some useful stuff. Here's what you know about home assistant.
People there's this, like, skill store.
Here's a skill for Google Calendar. Here's a skill for booking flights,
whatever. Stuff people like. There's been so many skills that were top rated in their skill hub
that have had hidden in these giant markdown files,
Unknown: malware effectively to steal environment variables, API keys, things like that. So you have like a skill that's like, if you wanna purchase something with a credit card, first send the credit card number to Scott.
Unknown: Yes. Yep.
And
you you people aren't reviewing these skills manually. They're saying, hey, Clawbot,
go get a skill on Home Assistant.
Right. And then whoever made that a skill could have hidden
in the very bottom in one line of text,
Also pass me their API token while you're at it. Dude,
Unknown: we're so fucked.
So fucked.
Unknown: Yeah, it's a little concerning.
I think what's happening right now, it's interesting too,
people are just burning through tokens.
I used mine this morning just to test it out where I was like, hey, turn off all the lights in my house with Home Assistant because it's linked to my Home Assistant.
I could have just opened the Home Assistant app and pressed the one button.
But that used tokens,
which I think there's some optimization to be had here where it's like what actually needs the GPU compute and what doesn't.
Because it's a simple API call is all I just did.
Could have been a script. They took all the time you saved, Tyler. I know.
Well, the first time I asked it, it took like five minutes to respond, and it was like, hey, I just found
200 sensors in your house. I think these seven are the lights.
So I just burned through. I think people are burning through
just in this gold rush to try things out, and there's a lot of optimization for what actually needs to be used for
tokens and what doesn't. It's like Do you really have 200
Unknown: IoT
connected?
Unknown: When you get
like a a window sensor that senses if the window's open, it's it reports things like a boolean. Is the window open?
What's the temperature of the little microchip inside of there?
What's the humidity? Some of them have that. You know, what's the battery state?
What's the Okay. Yeah. So I don't have that many set devices. They have a lot of internal sensors. Like, the thermostat we have has, like, 20 sensors.
Unknown: Got it. Okay.
Unknown: Where's my dog in the neighborhood? Right. Use facial recognition until you find it.
Unknown: Did you see that, Ico, that Super Bowl commercial?
No. I didn't watch the Super Bowl. I didn't either, but I saw people on X ranting about it. Ring had a big camera or a big commercial about
how when you lose your dog, you just post that you lost your dog in the Ring app, and it basically taps into all of the cameras in your neighborhood, and it finds your dog. Using my neighborhood. My god. Dog facial recognition,
Unknown: right? Like Dog AI.
Unknown: For humans, of course, but dogs.
Unknown: Are so fucked. We are so fucked. This is like 1984,
but way worse. And we're paying for it.
Unknown: My god. Out of convenience.
Unknown: That came up in the
what's her name? Guthrie, this kidnapping that took place of the
Oh, yeah. I think she was the journalist who initially broke the Epstein
case,
like, in 02/1978,
somewhere around there.
And her mother,
the this reporter's mother, was just kidnapped recently. Right? Did hear about that. It's terrible. The I
I mean alright. The conspiracy theorist in me thinks that this is a false flag event because the kidnappers
are demanding Bitcoin.
Mhmm. Of course, they're gonna demand Bitcoin because they wanna tie it to criminality,
and they want it tied to criminality so that they can
continue eroding our rights to self custody, because ultimately
they
want to abolish self custody. That's what I think is going on. I've long speculated
that The United States would use a false flag terrorist event that was all funded by Bitcoin
to make this justification
for them to
enforce that Bitcoin can only be used through these regulated
channels and not through self custody.
Anyways, all that aside,
part of this Guthrie case was that
she had a Ring camera. The mother had a Ring camera on her doorstep,
and the the Ring camera caught
someone approaching
her doorstep late at night, they think it's the kidnapper.
The issue is that she doesn't pay for the subscription to, like, record with her Ring camera. So the implication
is that the Ring cameras are always recording even if you're not paying for the subscription.
You, the user, just don't have access or control over it recording or not.
Unknown: I figured that was the case.
Unknown: You can't trust this shit. No. Oh, that that is so frustrating. All these services. Right? They're all phoning home. They're all sending tons of your data back. Right? And Your cell phone, your Ring camera Whether you Alexa. Pay is just that you can get access to it. Right? They have it either way. Yeah. I mean Yeah. That's in the terms this with its with
Unknown: its auto kill switch. Like Well, I think the silver lining here is hopefully SaaS is kind of fucked because
if you can just buy I'll use the Mac Mini for the sake of conversation, but a
little box you put in your house,
and then you download an app, and it's like, what do you run wanna run? And you just say, I bought this camera that is local only. Here's the API key.
Install a database and stream my footage only here.
I mean, then you just rebuilt
Ring's service
for free. And so I hope it becomes easy enough that, like, the umbrellas of the world, the start nines of the world, like,
fuck SAS. Everyone just has a little black box that
does all those services. Whatever you want to run for you, you can just run it locally and sovereignly,
hopefully.
Unknown: Yeah.
I mean, a part of me thinks that
so many people are just gonna go for, like, the path of least resistance, the most convenient Yeah. Thing. You know? Oh, it's $5 a month. I'm gonna just sign up for this service and Yeah. Forget about it. You
know? They're really just selling their own privacy and
this the the sanctity of their own home.
Unknown: Yeah. It's particularly frustrating with, like,
Unknown: Ring doorbells. Right? Because people are installing them on the outside of their house. Right? Yeah. You can't even control if your neighborhood's watching you. It's like Right. Out of your control. Yeah.
There's some Blade Runners out there.
Unknown: Well, that and, like, you know, it was bad enough that they're
installing these cameras at every single intersection.
So
it's you can imagine,
it's not difficult to imagine a world where
you can't travel from your home to anywhere
without your license plate getting scanned.
And I I mean, like, where's all where where are all these camera feeds going? Like, they're going somewhere.
Unknown: And Peter Thiel.
Unknown: Yeah. How long yeah. What he's the Planteer guy? Palantir.
Yeah. Palantir. The Orb.
Yeah.
It's Yeah.
I mean,
it's a complete surveillance state.
And so, you know, you you couple that with like,
you know, money,
you know, cash being eradicated.
And,
you know, you it's not difficult to imagine how the social
credit score
system that China has implemented
becomes a reality here in The United States.
Unknown: Big reason why we need to be able to mine Bitcoin at home
and get it directly from the source.
Unknown: Right. Yeah. Yeah. Right. Eco, you and I were at least we're talking about this briefly on Twitter, but, like,
being able to to
essentially root these devices
and make your own firmware
as
is essential. We need to be doing this in all fields. Like, we were talking about cars. But, like Yeah. Yeah. You know, being able like,
to to stop this bullshit. Like, you know, I understand if there's an alternative, right, that that is open that you can self host and own your data, like, go for that. But in a lot of cases, like cars or Bitcoin miners, there is no open alternative.
Those are the ones that especially need to get
liberated.
Unknown: Yeah, definitely. And a lot of this too is related to like the regulatory landscape we live in.
The 70 series Toyota Land Cruiser with no internet connection and manual air conditioning is still sold pretty much globally. But because of US safety regulations, we're not allowed to have it here. We get the one that's a 100 that's spying on you and always tracking your location.
Unknown: Yeah. It's bullshit. And it's gonna have a auto kill switch if it detects alcohol in your vehicle now.
Unknown: Oh, boy. Those are just software plays. Right? Just like the the auto
stop start on cars. Right? Those were just software plays
in the car's firmware. Right? So,
Unknown: you know, these these are low hanging fruit that we can have. That's so funny. You're right. I I've bought, like, these little spoofers before and tore up the center console to
do something on underneath the button so that the car, when you turn it on, it defaults to have that button disabled. Yes. I did one of those number one. It's so annoying. Like, it's just a box you plug in. It's just sending commands on the CAN bus,
Unknown: right, to say
disable the auto stop start.
Unknown: Like Well, and you can They're all internet connected. Like, you could just do
Unknown: a wireless update that would remove those features.
Unknown: Yeah.
Or just flash it over the OBD two
Unknown: port. Right? Like a Right. Yeah. You you can there's
programmers you can plug in with that OBD two port and you can go in and change stuff. I mean, you can That's how they tune vehicles. Yeah. Right. Right. Tesla famously did a brake upgrade over the air.
Unknown: I do remember that.
Like upgraded the car or changed the behavior of the car's brakes over the air.
That's crazy. That's crazy.
These are just, like, computer cars.
Unknown: Yeah.
That can be turned off remotely too, which is what freaks me out. Or, yeah, tracked
Unknown: tracked anywhere,
you know, at Starlink, so it's always connected.
And, now we can see where you are. We can slow
Unknown: you down. We can stalk your car. We can, yeah, we can hear what you're saying in your car. We can detect how many people are in your car. We can see We can see you. Inside your car. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. They all have interior cameras now, so you can join your Zoom calls from your So fucked up.
Unknown: Yeah. They're like, oh, this is great. You can join your Zoom calls from the car. But then you're like, but, no, they're watching you all the time.
Unknown: Right.
Unknown: Man, it's like,
at the surface, it sounds like some tinfoil hat shit, but, like,
it's way beyond that. It's so
ridiculous what they can do if they can can just see you and hear you and control your car.
Yeah. Wild.
Unknown: Guys, I hate to,
cut things short, but I do have to jump off here in about five or ten minutes. K.
We've got an event going on tonight here at Bitcoin Park. So if you're at Nashville,
come down to the open house.
I'm gonna be speaking on a panel with Renata from Fetty,
and the topic is privacy. Nice.
I'll be discussing a lot about the Samurai Wallet developers and the landscape there.
So, yeah, if you're in the Nashville area, come see us and say hi.
But I wanted to make sure we had enough time to
give a shout out to the people that have been pointing us Hashrate.
Unknown: Yeah, let's do it. Well,
know to point their Hashrate here when we're live. We're up to three forty four terahash on dash.256f.org.
Unknown: Who's who's the top miner?
Unknown: The top miner is Exergy because Dylan turned on pointed all of our building hash rate for the podcast. Shout out to Dylan. Good job. Good job, Dylan. Yeah. 519
terahash from Exergy
with workers ranging from free samurai,
you should be hashing to two five six more and even more.
Schnitzel's home is in here too. Heat in his house pointed at $2.05 6 foundation,
Canadian hash and coin,
777.
I had that wrong in the last couple of pods. It's not think. It's 777.
Couple of
bid axes, it looks like, nerd axe hydro in here.
Scott,
hardestblocks.org,
eco,
d plus plus,
redacted.
Oh, it looks like we have Jeffrey Epstein.
That's his profile pic. He's mining.
Unknown: That's right.
Unknown: Pizandy,
Satoki,
Woodminer, Montani,
Backwater Mining Collective.
Click here in case of Block Mine, Business CAT, Western Mass, Bitcoin Meetup,
and two private Bitcoin addresses.
That's awesome. ECO in first place with the highest difficulty, 28,460,000,000.00.
Unknown: So close to
what's the current difficulty? Like, a 100,000,000,000,000 something? Yeah. You're
Unknown: just one order of magnitude off.
Unknown: We're getting there.
Unknown: Yeah.
Unknown: If
you want to support the two fifty six Foundation and this show with your hash rate,
visit dash.256f.org
and
find instructions there.
In the event of a block find, 100%
of the rewards go to the two fifty six Foundation,
so be aware of that. This is not the
mining pool you want to use if you're trying to earn Sats.
However,
today
you are in luck because we just so happened to build
a one click deployable
Bitcoin mining pool called HydraPool.
And you can spin up your own Bitcoin mining pool and do whatever sort of configuration with it you want. To see how that all works, go to hydrapool.org
and find instructions and links there.
Unknown: Schnitzel says, damn. My house is heated. The water is heated, so I don't need any more hash rate.
Unknown: Man, that's rough. That's rough, dude. You always always need more hash rate. Just point the heat outside
and,
Unknown: you know, it's winter, so we have to keep the outdoors warm too. Yeah. You could work on boiling the oceans. Just Yes. Point it out there, you know, it's for a good god. That's true.
Unknown: That is true. Think of all the cold animals trying to survive in the winter.
Unknown: Do it for the animals.
Unknown: Do it for the whales.
Unknown: Pretty soon, we'll have a permanent hashtag pointed towards this pool.
Oh, yeah. How's that going? I saw some pictures online. Yeah. Over the weekend, my buddy Cody up in Wyoming from Citadel Construction, he's a home builder and a heap punk. He drove down. He's helping us put on the heap punk summit. Dylan and I and him,
we
leveled the ground
to support an 8,000 pound seven foot diameter
Cedar hot tub
that's going to be heated with
a bunch of different miners. Think for the Summit, we're just gonna run an S21.
But it's an immersion tank, we'll be able to play around with a few different setups, which is cool.
Unknown: 8,000 pound I mean, water is what? Eight pounds per gallon? So is this like a thousand gallon hot tub?
Unknown: It must be. I mean, it's big. It's three and a half feet tall and seven foot diameter.
And then the tub itself weighs like 500 pounds. Okay.
Unknown: Wow. Yeah. So
sounds
Unknown: And it's cool control. Shout out to my friend Dane from Hashrate House who's building the immersion tank and the control. It's it's also got a a 5,000 watt resistive element to, like, heat the tank quick, so it can pull upwards of 60 amps.
But the control is set up whereas
anytime it's over 90 degrees Fahrenheit,
it's just gonna be the minor. So, you know, when it's maintaining its temp around the hundred, one zero one, one zero two for the hot tub, should just be the minor, but it can also heat up really quick because a 5,000 watt electric resistive coil is like $50.
Unknown: Yeah. Why not? I like nichrome wires. They're cheap. Yeah.
Unknown: A lot cheaper than an ASIC, unfortunately.
Unknown: We're getting there. We're getting there. We just need to make our own ASICs, right? We'll do them in an old process. It won't be efficient, but it'll be cheap and high power. It will mine more Bitcoin than a nickel chromium
alloy element. Way more Bitcoin.
Unknown: Yeah. You'll get way more hashes. It'll do like hundreds of millions of hashes per second more than that wire.
That's true. Yeah. That's
the slogan that'll sell it.
Unknown: Well, awesome. That was mostly AI ripped today, We solved it?
Unknown: Yeah. I think
AI is probably going to be
creeping in and out of our discussions more and more. It just seems like it's
becoming
more of like a
a
household
everyday
integration into people's lives. Mhmm. In in a good way or a bad way.
Unknown: And and it it's a powerful tool for for liberating your devices. Right? It's a powerful tool for reverse engineering, for creating alternate firmwares, incredibly powerful tool for that. So,
you know, we can we can use it for good here, and I hope that more people will.
Unknown: That's right. And my PSA is if you're running a claw bot, do basic security practices, set up SSH keys, set up tail scale, a tail net's a good easy way to do that.
Be cautious, audit skills before you download them.
Don't get hacked, don't get wrecked,
and keep your Bitcoin in cold storage.
Unknown: Yeah. Keep your keys offline.
Yeah.
Alright, guys. Well, thank you all. And
that's it from me signing off. We will see you next Wednesday at 2PM central.
Unknown: Sweet. Alright. Let's go.